the yav Vango Delta is a biodiversity
Hotpot in the heart of one of Africa's
most important fresh water
[Music]
systems its p is maintained by river
structure that begins deep in dangan
Highlands in an area locals called liima
Yono the source of life one half is a
constant flow the quit river is steady
caring nutrient Rich water from Angola's
hidden Source Lakes released slowly
through miles of pit lands the other
half drives the P the cubango is
unpredictable Rocky and rough is water
flows faster pumping seasonal floods
into the
system on namibia's border with Angola
these two lifelines become the cabango
[Music]
river which becomes the okavanga river
in Botswana where red beds and floating
Papyrus Islands filter the water before
diffusing into the aavang
Delta this system is as vital as it is
delicate if anything begins to affect it
the consequences could be
catastrophic that's why National
Geographic and DBS are working through
the okavanga Eternal partnership
building on work done by local
communities to know the rivers and the
ecology that keeps them alive through
intense Expeditions cutting Ed research
Technologies and expert indigenous
guidance they building an understanding
of how this ecosystem Works sharing the
research with local organizations and
policy makers to better protect it
keeping a finger on the PSE making sure
the heart of the Kango keeps
[Music]
beating